do you think people who live in cities
should escape the cities right now
um you know so one of the things i've
got in the intro chapter
is you know here's a three-year here's a
one-year plan you're you're ready to
move what do you need to do here's a
three-year plan
and one of the things i have is a
10-year plan for young adults because
i've had a lot of you know friends on
twitter who are 22 or 26
ask me and you know i've said on the
10-year plan don't move
right the second you know the cities
aren't about to collapse tomorrow what
you need to do
is uh learn a skill you need to learn
some stuff and you need to find your
mate
um it's a lot easier to meet people in
the city than it is out in the middle of
nowhere
so you don't think i think people should
be getting away from cities immediately
okay well
that's going to help me sell the book uh
so i agree tim i've never heard an idea
that's so right
with with you know you look at how the
the law is being enforced
um it's been referred to uh i know mike
mike cernovich tweeted about this
i think um maybe michael miles may have
mentioned it and arco tyranny absolutely
and those are two good followers i
followed with these guys as well so
those aren't familiar narco tyranny is
basically that the government doesn't
enforce
the crimes and petty things that are
negatively impacting your life you're
being robbed
but they do enforce anything that uh
goes against them in any way
or the powerful elites yeah so
absolutely arson during riots well
that's just a bit of vibrant democracy
you know that went you know two percent
too far but on the other hand you know
some
white-collar guy has a pistol that you
know isn't known to the attorney general
to have all 17 of the checkpoints and
you know he gets dragged through the
system and he's lucky if he you know
gets off with that jail time after he
spent a hundred thousand dollars on
legal fees i see this
i see this as being you know for the
most part where we are i mentioned that
you know joe biden clearly isn't
speaking to half the country and that's
a failure on his part i mean you look at
what uh
jenn sackey issued one of the most
shocking statements when she said that
they were working with facebook
oh my horrifying when the bind
administration is now admitting that
they're working with the dnc
to go to phone carriers to censor
private text messages
it is it is beyond it it is our anarcho
tyranny yeah they're riots in the
streets
that the crime is skyrocketing the
police are being defunded yet the
government is coming after
private citizens to an extreme degree
there was a great quote uh i think it
was from p.j o'rourke i read it 10 or 20
years ago
which is that uh peta goes after
women wearing fur coats and not bikers
wearing leather jackets
part of the explanation behind a narco
tyranny you know i mentioned earlier
that i studied
roman history and one thing in the later
days of the empire the
roman political elite wanted triumphs
which was a big parade through downtown
rome because it looked great you have
treasure and the problem is that to
conquer a
tough foreign tribe is hard and there's
not many of them they're far away
so at some point the roman political
elites started waging war against allies
and their own provinces
um because it was a way to you know kill
a bunch of people and take some treasure
yeah um and so this ties into a narco
tyranny
who's easier to prosecute sort of you
know some uh you know
high ranking uh you know corruption or
just pick a random white collar guy
you know you know i'm i'm just i'm at
this point
sick of people who are the frog in the
pot boiling who refuse to accept what is
happening around them because i've had
so many conversations where i'm like
listen
you know i'm not trying to be a
doomsayer
i am not absolutely predicting what will
happen i'm only simply asking
if everything we've seen over the past
10 years has been escalating
do you think it is more likely that the
escalation will continue
or that right now the escalation will
stop and things will improve right
that's a great way to frame it but
that's um so i'm not saying i mean quite
literally
tomorrow joe biden could come out and
say i want to issue a heartfelt sincere
apology to all of trump's supporters for
everything that's happened in this
country and i want to know that i am
here for you
and i'm going to be sitting down and you
know he could he could say something he
won't
right what does he say he says the
republicans voting bills is the greatest
threat since the civil war
they no one no one is backing down and
no one will stop this gets into the
rhetoric where
nazi and racist are the ultimate trump
cards uh you know the civil war so this
is implicitly putting anyone who doesn't
agree
with you know sort of every policy of
the democratic party is obviously on the
side of bringing back slavery
civil war he's saying it at a time when
when we have this this poll coming out
whether the polls accurate or not
and the sentiment is rising for for a
breakup of this country
i can only say that a president who
would say that is encouraging
and he's an accelerationist yep he wants
it to happen now i can say this over and
over again
i do not want anything bad to happen to
this country and i think the divide is
horrifying because of what
will happen with our enemies the last
thing i want is for china to take taiwan
now no no chips for computers and cars
and china controls that
they gain more control in all of these
other regions as they are expanding with
the belt and road initiative
we need a strong united america joe
biden i think is doing everything to rip
it apart
you know um there's an essay i read once
uh
i think was by this guy clark hat um on
status 451 blog talking about the
machinery of state and state machines
and the idea is that
there are things that can roll forward
but that can't roll back the same way
and you can see it in mechanical
engineering with worm gears and
everything
and i'm not sure what the output of this
is i mean accelerationism and the
collapse of the united states
sounds terrible but if we were in the
kind of system where we could back up we
would have already backed up so
i don't know how we get out i i've
talked to so many people um
and i mentioned this frequently
particularly in the past week or so with
this poll that came out
talk of the city's trap the mit study
that came you saw the mit thing i did
not
1972 mit said was it might it was mit
right uh
i don't know this tied into the core of
waves and i i think they said by 2040
society will collapse due to these
factors and everything like that i'm
like
i'm looking at all these things i'm
looking at a vice president who's saying
this is the biggest threat since the
civil war
and he said the confederates never made
it to the capitol and i'm like wow
dude you're saying these these trump
supporters there were hundreds of
thousands of people who didn't go in the
capital
you're likening trump's base to the
confederates
how could that not be accelerationism
but i see this i've seen so many people
over the past several years tell me i
was wrong or crazy to think that we're
headed towards some kind of civil
conflict
and i'm like bro we're in it yeah we are
in it and and
you know how could we have come to this
point i had a conversation recently with
someone who's like nah
nah everything's gonna be fine it's
gonna calm down we're all gonna go back
to normal and i'm like
why because trump's gonna decide not to
run because trump's gonna just disappear
overnight
or do you think 2022 trump's going to be
doing the circuit promoting people in
the midterms
the media is going to find their path
towards making money again and so that
doesn't matter what's true or not
they're gonna go they're absolutely
insane rile people up to an extreme
degree
and then we're gonna have three years of
that and you think it's gonna be all
fine
you know i think so i'm agreeing with
your overall thesis but i think even if
trump
dropped dead from a heart attack
tomorrow the
two tribes have been led to hate each
other so much and this is you know uh
fuel uh the media loves it uh the
democrats
love it um and because it gets
excitement it gets people out to the
polls it gets donations the new york
times loves it i mean the new york times
has been hugely
more uh profitable over the last few
years than it ever was before
um and so the aclu is the perfect
example oh god you know
they used to be wonderful i mean i i
lean more to the right than to the left
but i always loved the aclu is man they
stick by their principles and even
i who disagree with most of the members
of it on free speech they rock
but what happened was they made a bunch
of money when they challenged donald
trump's moratorium on travel from the
seven countries
and then they got a bunch of flack over
charlottesville
and so they immediately said money is
more important than values
yep and we've seen that with many
different organizations
i mean there used to be a concept of
academic freedom where okay uh
this one professor with his crazy ideas
you know disagrees with all decent
society but we respect free speech and
free inquiry so much that we will
support him in this
and you know that was a useful tool
until the left could entirely finish
their long march through the
institutions
but now that they've got it there's no
academic freedom at all if you want to
say anything that departs from the party
line by two percent you can get fired
i look at these non-profits um and i
look at
the the media and i'm just like there i
don't think there's a point at which
the two different versions of reality
ever meet so there's a i love calling
this organization free press.net you
ever hear of them yeah
yeah what do you what do you think
they're supposed to be representing
um from the title uh i would think the
free press now would you be surprised to
find out they were advocating censorship
i would not be surprised exactly what
they've been in 1984 man yep
they they came through heavily against
alex jones saying he must be censored
and banned and removed
and i knew people there and i hit him up
and i was like what are you doing
and they were like this is important you
know he spreads lies and i'm like you're
the free press
of course you're gonna defend people who
will say bad things so you have to
there's this current uh push right now
to get rid of misinformation and i'm
reading a book i was reading it on the
airplane about the
uh soviets how they almost invented the
internet they had a couple of networking
um
attempts in the 50s 60s 70s and
they had the whole concept of you know
cybernetics which came from the us and
uh then the soviets were
playing with it and there was one part
of cybernetics and information theory
and claude shannon and everything that
immediately had resonance with them and
that was
static or noise in the system because it
fit into their ideology you could talk
about information on the one hand and
noise on the other and that was chilling
to read this in the book about
the soviet internet attempts of the
1970s because we're hearing it every day
with oh of course we have free speech
but not for misinformation and like oh
man
and you see what uh um was it npr said
that the truth
with not proper context is
misinformation wonderful so
what's proper context right framing yep
so when the guardian comes out with an
article that says
the kremlin seems to have compromise on
trump or according to a document
and then all of these people the
establishment left just read the
headline and don't actually read the
story
they believe that we have the proof that
trump is compromised then you read the
actual story what do they say
it's highly unusual suspect the kremlin
denies it
trump denies it and we haven't confirmed
any documents but experts think it may
be real
right okay so none of it's confirmed why
did you publish it but if you read
nothing about the headline
there you go it's proof you know
snopes.com is amazing these days because
uh
we'll have a politician say you know the
sun rises in the east
and um you know then snopes will say you
know this is absolutely false without
more context because actually the earth
is rotating and the sun stands still
man well the way i always describe it to
people is that what they'll do is
there there'll be a video of donald
trump doing a backflip off of you know a
balcony and landing perfectly in a
superhero pose
everyone will share the video it'll go
viral it'll get 10 million views and
every conservative will say wow this
trump is spry
you know for a 77 year old man and then
snopes will say
did donald trump do a perfect backflip
off of a balcony and land in a superhero
pose
on sunday mm-hmm and then they'll say
false then it'll give you a bunch of
exposition garbage and like on saturday
you know the 15th donald trump was
giving a speech
and then trump known liar finally
exactly without evidence had made these
claims and finally at the bottom after
five
600 words it'll say while trump did do a
perfect backflip
and he did land in a superhero pose it
was on sunday
uh it was on monday at midnight right
which is not sunday right
right which in eastern time zone is not
sunday yeah exactly that's the game
i've been thinking about how we we're
talking earlier about how it's not a
linear we're talking about the
accelerationism
essentially and it's not linear it's
like it's kind of like a j curve right
which makes me think of that it's
the beginning of an amplification wave
that may come back down
so maybe it's not going to keep going
maybe you know every exponential curve
is an s curve
once you get to the end of it and so
what's what causes it to amplify greater
is coherent interference we've got like
all this fake news
saying the same stuff creating this
amplification wave if we create some
sort of d
coherent d coherent interference uh
maybe we can reduce the amplification
and slow
the acceleration it seems plausible um
you know
i tend to i i've gotten sort of a
political or post post-political or
something over the last couple of years
not because i don't think politics
matters you know this is fascinating
stuff and i love to sit here and analyze
it
um and i love to you know sort of go
back and read old books and see what you
know uh correlations we can get
um but i think these systems are huge
and by systems i mean sort of you know i
i'm pro-free market but capitalism at
this point
is this massive you know sort of
headless monster with seven billion
people in it
and you know capitalism is going to do
what it's going to do it's like
evolution you you know you get perfect
sharks
uh you may not want a shark but it
doesn't matter and you know you get the
perfect facebook you get the perfect
uh you know et cetera and you get the
perfect democratic party and you get the
perfect republican party so it's only a
matter of time look at the perfect
movies
yeah movies have whittled down to the
lowest common denominator of giant
robots blowing stuff up yeah
it used to be like groundhog day you
know yeah it's gonna be perfect like
you're like
and so my response to this is mostly to
just pull back and disconnect
and so you know i've got my friends i've
got you know
good old books that i read um yeah i
think this
is the d coherent interference talking
about things that aren't in that
narrative is creating a d coherence
which is reducing the amplification
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time